so what do you think
about uh the the jake paul
guys on the um i think that's very
interesting i'm looking forward to see
that before my fight
it's it's it's really um
listen jake paul dwight do right
yeah he looks really good in the midst i
don't know how he's going to the ripper
and the messi looked like he could fight
i mean he fought ksi right uh it was
logan paul
ksi and jake paul was on the undercard
on that one but jake paul's fought
a couple times i mean the thing about
these youtubers fighting
whether you wanna like hate on it
whether they're they're good whether
they're bad
the [ __ ] thing is that they've got
people
paying to watch it they've got to know
but more than that they got
balls yeah they have balls and to never
really do and doing in front of a bunch
of people and everybody's watching
forgetting the crowds in there not
that takes balls yup yeah i i mean
i'm pretty impressed even just with the
with their fighting
that freaks me out because this is
something we do for a living and
you know this was something people avoid
their whole life
and to go in there wasn't doing you know
this is crazy
i think it was really exciting it's
really exciting i think it was a good
business decision to get
jake paul on like on the card man i like
that guy
yeah yeah they have a fight coming up
soon that's that's the same card
november 12th november 28th it's
november 28th
okay november [ __ ] 28th dude
and uh and it's pay-per-view but you but
you own the league
yes i'm in the league of a league of my
own so now you're mike tyson
and don king well i'm definitely mike
tyson
but but you're the promoter yeah yeah
[ __ ] a man
yeah dude